just voyeur started with today's video I
do want to thank today's sponsor total
AV for making it possible back in the
day when you got a computer ya got
antivirus software it was just what you
did but today we don't really worry
about it so much but malware is more
sophisticated than ever and everyone
should have good anti-virus yes even if
you have a Mac this still applies to you
one of the biggest problems today is
spyware which can harvest your data and
collect personal information on you such
as usernames passwords and browsing
information indeed last year hackers
stole half a billion personal records
that's where total AV comes in
protecting you they'll keep you safe
against malware ransomware spyware and
phishing attacks totally detect and
remove viruses adware and other things
that might remain undetected on your
computer you can get one year of total
av Pro antivirus for just $19.99 that's
80% offenses if you're not happy 30-day
money-back guarantee and let's get into
it
[Applause]
[Music]
if I asked you to think of a country
where more than 80% of the inhabitants
live in state built homes many will
surely think of a socialist republic or
maybe a former Soviet bloc country right
well what if I told you that this figure
corresponds to one of the countries with
the freest and most deregulated
economies possibly the most capitalist
country in the world surprised while
Singapore is an unusual case an
exception in terms of housing models the
Southeast Asian city-state famous for
its towering skyscrapers impossible
architecture and that being one of the
largest financial centers in the world
has developed a public housing system
that is globally unique so something you
might now be thinking if you're a
regular subscribers but Simon you
already told us on this very channel
that Vienna also has an extensive public
housing system and well yes you're
absolutely right however we're talking
about two very different models
completely different models in fact
[Music]
the great difference between Vienna and
Singapore's model lies particularly in
the percentage of property owners while
the Viennese model is oriented towards
rentals three-quarters of the population
rents City Council owned homes a
Singapore model is just the opposite
more than 90 percent of Singapore
citizens own their own homes
of course 80 percents own homes promoted
built and granted by the state
[Music]
yes we're talking ownership oriented
public housing ownership with a few
catches if we're being completely honest
here but we'll talk about that later
first we need to ask ourselves some
questions
why does Singapore apparently reject the
free market real-estate model how on
earth can they develop a property
oriented public housing system how is
this model affected private real estate
developments and is the Singapore model
replicable in other countries while
let's get to the bottom of all of these
questions shall we Singapore a small
land in a huge population dear friends
of visual politic first we need to
familiarize ourselves with the context
check out this map Singapore is the
city-state with just over 700 square
kilometers but with more than five and a
half million inhabitants this has forced
more than 70 percent of the land to be
built on those are the red areas of map
the remaining 30% includes mostly
protected areas or lands where one
simply cannot build
[Music]
basically the city is overflowing faced
with such a scenario it wouldn't be
unreasonable to think that accessing a
home in Singapore would be a headache
would it after all that's the case in
similar places such as Hong Kong well
strangely enough it isn't the reason has
a lot to do with Singapore's unique
urban development model check this out
in 1960 the Singapore government created
the Housing and Development Board a
public housing company that is
responsible for regulating and managing
the land as well as building and
developing real estate projects and
that's because since 1967 most of the
land in Singapore has been publicly
owned
in that yet 1967 the so-called land
acquisition Act was approved this
enabled government to take back
ownership of all of the land that means
the land marketed for real estate
development is made available and the
housing board's criteria that is there
isn't a price system in a land
commercialization
[Music]
let me explain it another way this
public body determines how many homes it
will build into what prices and under
what conditions they will be marketed
evidently always below the potential
market price on the other hands it's
this same organization this Housing and
Development Board which draws lands for
auction so private developers can build
completely private real estate projects
[Music]
of course sin in every case the land
continues to be publicly owns that is
the home owners cannot do whatever they
want with it for example they can't sell
their homes to build a hotel and the
property is more a concession than a
property now I want to explain what a
citizen of Singapore and I emphasize
this because foreigners can't buy new
public housing gets one of these homes
they aren't really acquiring the lands
ownership nor the house itself but only
the right to stay in it that kind of
lease that lasts for 99 years after that
period the house returns to the state
this is how the prime minister of
Singapore explains it after 99 years the
flat comes back to the state the
government redeveloped the land and
builds new flats for future generations
this is the only way to recycle the land
to ensure all our descendants can buy
new flats on their own if instead the
government sold you the flat on freehold
sooner or later we would run out of land
to build new flats lee seon long prime
minister of Singapore and you have to be
careful because in private developments
this period may be even shorter
[Music]
of course during the lease period the
owners can do whatever they deem
appropriate with the house if they don't
want to live in ads they can sell it or
they can rent it
[Music]
in fact it is an uncommon if things are
going well for those who older homes do
sell or rent the public homes which tend
to be very austere especially the old
ones in order to move into private
developments which in Singapore's case
are far more luxurious but the
peculiarities of this carrier system
they don't end there
[Music]
since the body that builds and sells
most homes is public the government uses
it as a social policy instrument or
rather an instrument of social
engineering for example to avoid the
formation of ghettos given that
Singapore's population has a certain
racial diversity a building or
development's dwellings are allocated in
such a way that the proportion of owners
has an ethnic distribution that reflects
the distribution in the whole country a
[Music]
population distribution by ethnic group
in Singapore it looks something like
this in each block of homes the owners
are distributed more or less in the same
way if a block or project has for
example a hundred homes then we'll find
74 Chinese owners 13 Malaysian owners
nine Indian owners and so on however
last not a bad thing perhaps the worst
aspect of this model is that the
government uses the granting of homes do
promote certain life models for example
traditional couples don't have any
problem applying for government property
but single people or same-sex couples
well let's just say it's much more
complicated for them
surprised it is a bit strange to find
such interventional ism in a supposedly
capitalist place but it shouldn't be
surprising we already told you that
Singapore's political economic and
social model is kind of a mix between
free-market capitalist policies and very
very paternalistic policies where the
state actively promotes certain ways of
life and punishes others
[Music]
in this case in the area of housing not
only in housing allocation but also for
example mortgage approvals conditions
are very advantageous for people who
meet the state-imposed criteria Jones
well bad luck to you
[Music]
want to live alone well sorry I live
with the friends too bad you want to
live with your same-sex partner well you
know we wish we could help but uh
probably not gonna work out
[Music]
now beyond these rather questionable
practices truth is that this system has
been quite successful public housing is
much more affordable in Singapore than
in other cities with comparable economic
success such as London Sydney or Hong
Kong on average new buyers spent less
than a quarter of their income on their
mortgage but just a second all of this
isn't free
[Music]
the economic invoice dilemma if the
government of Singapore is known for one
thing it's for keeping taxes and public
spending Bey however things are
different with the whole housing issue
the system is clearly lacking HDB
reports one point four seven billion
dollar loss in latest financial year as
fewer flats sold 1.5 billion dollars
that's the difference between what
urbanization and construction work costs
the state and the income it receives
from selling the homes
that's 1.5 billion dollars that is
financed from the public budget the
whole housing scheme is basically
financed with taxes regardless of land
ownership this is the annual allocation
that the Singapore government devotes to
its housing policy perfectly acceptable
amount for an economy as big as
Singapore's now does this mean that the
governments of other countries should
take back ownership of city lands and
oversee housing development just like
the Singapore government does well no
not at all
[Music]
singapore's case is very particular
we're talking about a city state with
huge economic success state which is
managed almost like a company and where
lands limitations are more than evidence
the differences with other countries
quite obvious nor is it cleared that if
it were operating as a free market a
truly free one the results would be much
different not to mention the enormous
power that such systems grant
politicians to design societies at will
[Music]
but what Singapore has really achieved
with this model mence
I think it's undeniable has been to
develop an urban planning and real
estate price scheme that favors the
development of many other activities
with greater added value for example
given that housing prices are capped
Singaporean citizens have a greater
capacity to save and invest in for
example new businesses
anyway this is Singapore's unique model
yet another model is up for debate
so now it's your turn what do you think
of the Singaporean housing model well
leave your answer in the comments below
as always thanks to reconsider media for
providing the vocals in this episode but
were not mine please do like and
subscribe to this video and I'll see you
next time
[Music]